hi I'm Sadashiva PI from science mission
today we have a doctor
Newport from NC State
she's the professor of psychology there
she's a fellow of the gerontological
Society of America and the American
Psychological Association and currently
serves as an associate editor for The
Journal of gerontology psychological
sciences her research interests include
contextual and individual differences
surrounding stressors and well-being
outcomes in particular she is interested
in the psyche of psychosocial and socio
demographic characteristics of
individuals along with changing
contextual factors which may be related
to emotional physical and cognitive
reactivity to stressors welcome to
Newport thank you please talk about your
background interest and you are some of
the works you are doing I went to high
school in Seattle I grew up there and
then I went to college and Pepperdine
University it which is in California and
I thought I wanted to be a physician so
I was a biology major for almost two
years before I met organic chemistry two
of us did not get along I just I
realized that I needed to find something
that I found interesting and was more
passionate about without struggling to
really try to solve my way through it so
I found psychology which I was a really
nice way to stick with science that
appealed to me and then also to be able
to bring in human behavior and to try to
really develop my passion for thinking
about ways to improve health and
well-being especially in older adults so
I got my degree at Pepperdine thankfully
and then I went to Western Washington
University for my masters in general
psychology I wasn't quite sure what I
wanted to do at that time but I knew I
really liked research and
academia academia in general so I got a
masters in their program which focused
on measurement evaluation in statistical
analysis turns out I love statistics I
really was like this is fantastic
so then I went to Arizona for my PhD
which is in Family Studies and human
development and my minor for my PhD is
statistics so after my postdoc at
Brandeis I'm at NC State where I was
hired as a quantitative psychologist
okay and there is something about you at
a lab that people yes yeah I currently
have two graduate students one was in
her third year and one just started with
me and I have six undergraduate students
for this semester so next semester some
of the undergraduates are graduating
I'll have new ones coming in and I'm
recruiting new graduate students to the
lab as well so those numbers always tend
to fluctuate but right now there's nine
of us okay and how do you motivate this
bunch of okay yeah I like to make sure
that each person has something that they
care about that they're working on so I
meet individually with the graduate
students each week and we talk about
their progress in their lab related work
but also in their coursework in the
program of study in general and then I
meet with the undergraduates and our
weekly lab meetings and then as mean I
meet with them also because they each
are working on their own project their
first semester in the lab I have them go
to a local conference so they either
present a poster or give a talk in a
local conference on a project that they
care about and then their second
semester they work on writing up that
conference presentation for a
publication so many of them are now
working on finishing up their papers for
a journal article so I meet with them go
over more complicated analyses that
maybe haven't covered in their
undergraduate work and so I try to make
sure that they are working on something
they find interesting and then I kind of
move along 5min that yeah that's
interesting and can you talk about some
of the role models mentis you had in
your career yes I've been very fortunate
many excellent role models and mentors
when I was at Pepperdine and I actually
had a wonderful 2/6 professor that
people may have heard of for different
reasons dr. Christine Blasi as I knew
her then now christine Blasi forward she
was my physics professor and she really
got me excited about stats so I'm very
grateful to her for kind of turning me
on to that field and Cindy Miller Perrin
is also at Pepperdine she's still there
she really has a passion for psychology
and has been a fantastic mentor in terms
of how to think about doing academia and
balancing family and then Leslie
McDonald meshach was my Master's advisor
um I was only with her for two years
because it was a short master's program
but she encouraged me to continue on my
degree search and I went to Arizona
where I worked with Dave Almeida this
really shaped a lot of my thinking and
how daily stressors and daily events are
powerful makers of daily health and
well-being and he's also just a
fantastic person and then Margie Lachlan
was my mentor at Brandeis University
where I did my postdoc and she really
helped me understand and think about
people's perceptions of control which is
different from the actual control they
may have but their perception of and how
it can be important for shaping one's
environment or trying to achieve certain
goals and so I think you'll see although
those kinds of topics woven in
throughout my my shortly and like I know
you have small kids so how do you spend
time other than recess yeah yeah so my
children are small they're five and
three and my husband is also in academia
so it's nice to have a partner who
understands the ebb and flow of the work
and sometimes you know when he's at the
gym in the evening I'm sitting down and
I'm making editorial decisions or um and
that kids are sick you know we kind of
decide who is going to they home that
day we try to teach on alternate days of
the week so I teach on Mondays and
Wednesdays my husband teaches on
Tuesdays and Thursdays so
pretty clear who stays home if a child
gets sick one of those days so we do our
best to try to try to manage that but
sometimes you know it doesn't work out
that well my husband was at a conference
in Germany and our youngest got sick and
so I've had to take him to class with me
because nobody else could teach my class
and so I lectured on power analysis with
a two-year-old on my hip and the class
is like this is interesting but it works
like you just kind of make do so I feel
like there's a lot of integration that
happens and in work and family okay and
coming back to the spacer so what made
you got interested in the spacers and
what do you are doing right now yeah I
stressed specifically I would think back
to my time in Arizona when I was working
with Dave Almeida because he's very
interested in how the daily stressful
events that people encounter really
shape how we how we think about and
interact with our health and well-being
on a daily basis so he he has a lot of
work and he's really formed my thinking
and how daily stressors are powerful
predictors that we need to pay attention
to so some of my work now is long why
how we can maybe try to prevent or
reduce the impact of the stressors when
they do happen so that's that's where
I'm leaning towards now and my work in
general focusing on how aging related
processes may be important really tied
back to the strong relationships I had
with my grandparents when I was young
and even now at my my grandfather is 96
unfortunately I'll have a living
grandparent so it's yeah I've always had
positive views about aging so the
negative stereotypes that tend to be
pervasive in the u.s. culture at least
around aging I wasn't really exposed to
until later in my adult life so if it's
kind of formed why I do what I do
okay now can you please present your
workplace under yeah yeah yeah let me
share my screen
so I swept oh here we go so I've called
this daily well-being because it's a
it's a it's a broad context under which
a lot of my research falls and I've been
very fortunate to receive funding from
local university support as well as the
National various national external
research sources and I really interested
in these daily processes because I like
to start with this visual I feel like a
lot of how we perceive our lives or
interact with the with the events in our
lives come down to things that might
happen to us on a daily basis so
certainly major events like retirement
or getting married or death of a spouse
or definitely a parent those are very
important now I don't seek to minimize
those at all but when we look at
previous research that has focused on
the predictive power of those major life
events alongside the smaller seemingly
more minor daily events like arguments
are getting stuck in traffic it's the
daily events that are more important in
terms of predicting health and
well-being so there's a lot of work to
be done to understand how these daily
things that I think this daily grind
practically important things that we
need to spend a lot of focus on and so
I'm interested in the sources of
variability and how people may be
different from each other in their
health and well-being so these emojis
represent differences between people
some people are less healthy or happy
than others so the the person on the
Left right the you know years of
laughter like just you know so happy and
having a fabulous time they look very
different and the first on the far right
who seems to be very sad so those are
important differences between people but
in my work I'm also interested in the
daily variation so this within person or
fluctuating state where some days are
less happy or healthy than others and so
if we look at the
the emoji on the far left you know even
one day that person is reporting being
very sad and on the far right the person
who in general looked quite sad as some
at least one day of being quite happy
so there's important differences that we
can look at between people but then I'm
also interested in the fluctuations in
people and the way that I look at that
is by asking people the same questions
every day for a series of consecutive
days so I use daily diary designs and
try to get at both of these sources of
variability so I have three overlapping
and related areas of interest that I
focus on in my research and so I look at
reactivity to stressors or how people
respond to stressors after the event has
already happened I'm also interested in
what predicts things that come before
the stressors the antecedents of how we
might respond they're resilient way and
then lastly I'm interested in the time
scales over which these processes occur
whether they're short or long term
indications of inter-individual
variability so the first one I'll talk
about is reactivity distress surgeries
and Dave Almeida who's my PhD advisor
developed this conceptual model where he
talks about reactivity depressors so on
the left hand side the purple box
integrates these individual differences
or differences in people whether it
might be personality or perceptions of
control over one's life is Pro believes
age differences those may predict how
much stress we are exposed to so that
stressor exposure blue box but they also
may predict how we react to the
stressors once we happen the lower blue
box here and so I'm interested in both
the exposure piece so how many stressors
we experience and then also the
reactivity or the vulnerability to them
when they do happen and the
characteristics of the stressors are
important to consider so how many of
them what they are about the content the
severity how people think about them in
terms of the appraisal or the goals
they're relevant to their lives whether
it's a loss or
rat or a challenge in some way so these
are the thoughts that people have the
appraisals around the event itself and
then importantly how all of these things
feed into well-being on a daily basis so
I'm interested in outcomes like
psychological distress might be
emotional well-being was the other way
to think about that daily physical
symptoms and cognition and then these
things can be part of a feedback loop
where this process starts over again so
the first thing I want to share is this
idea of the content of the stressors the
data that I'll present first are from
the national study of daily experiences
it's a national telephone telephone
interview that took place on eight
consecutive evenings for each
participant there were a thousand
thirty-one adults across all 50 states
in the u.s. their age 25 to 74 there's a
lot of information that came from these
telephone interviews the three variables
that I'll focus on right now are the
daily psychological distress or the
negative mood that people might report
on a given day there are a number of
physical health symptoms and then the
daily stressors that they were exposed
to so Dave Almeida who is the project
principal investigator of this project
generated an inventory of how people can
report their daily stressors so it's a
series of seven questions where people
were asked if they had an argument or
disagreement on a given day if he had
anything stressful happen at work if
they had anything stressful happen at
home anything that might have happened
to a close friend or family member that
about to be stressful for them so these
are called social network stressors and
if anybody answered yes to those
questions and they were asked to
describe what happened so I want to
share a of a work stressor that a
participant reported so this person said
yes there was something stressful to
happen at work I ran out of something at
work some pop 7up they were late
bringing it so it was stressful just not
being able to provide it as stressful
during lunch time I don't like being
without it it is important want people
to have a choice so on the surface you
might think well this isn't really
something that's a big deal it's just
okay
ran out of 7up but if this person was in
charge of running a restaurant and had
to constantly remind the servers and the
patrons that I'm sorry 7f is not
available you could imagine that for
someone who really valued their job and
had a responsibility as a manager that
this could be a stressful situation so
when people told us that something
stressful happened and they were able to
articulate this kind of a narrative
around it we believed so we didn't we
didn't try to assign judgment about
whether or not something I'll Rose the
level thing and this is the point where
I get to cite Tina Fey so she has this
chart which of course you know she the
comedian so she it's rather silly but I
think it nicely articulates how we can
think about Bob's way so on the vertical
axis the y-axis the course is not to
scale comes from five to 100 to 1
million this is the what she called the
daily stress level of various jobs so
the first bar on the left is writing for
SNL and then we have acting on SNL but
apparently in her mind is significantly
different from her 30 rock writing job
so heading for 30 rock apparently for
her is more cool than acting on SNL then
with coal mining in the u.s. parrot
apparently they don't appear to be
significant according to her as far as
being a baby and then following business
boys who do stuff with money
I really don't know and then the highest
bar is active military service a very
long car ride a night this is somewhat
tongue-in-cheek but the idea is we
people who are in these gulps know their
jobs and they know their stress levels
the best and so we need to we need to
also imagine that the person reporting
is going to be the best the best insight
that we have into their to their works
best on okay so the nesic next example
is from a social network stressor also
this respondent said yes something
happened to my best friend her wedding
plans got cancelled because of me we
were supposed to be at the hall to view
the chapel and put some money down but
because we were late we didn't get it
someone else did
we're gonna have to have it at my house
which shows my labs upside down for two
days after rearrange my whole house
theme all in two days and with three
kids but certainly the difference
between running out of 7up and having a
wedding now at your house those are very
different kinds of experiences and so
participants also told us how stressful
they found these events so we have an
indication of their stress but this just
represents the different domains use the
espresso Hispanics are so good
see how people bond stress is various
domains so on this in this paper on the
vertical axis I'm predicting daily
psychological distress or daily negative
mood and these red lines indicate
people's responses to the increases in
stressors so a a steep line would be a
worse response means that they are
reacting more strongly to the professor
so in this case we're looking at
interpersonal stressors these would be
arguments or disagreements if I want to
have on a given day and this is the
result of a three-way interaction so
I've broken up the figure based on how
high or low people feel people reported
feeling in their personal control or
their feelings of control over their
life so on the left hand side for people
who report feeling a high amount of
constraint are people who feel like
there's a lot of obstacles in our way
from the environment that are preventing
them from meeting their goals so people
on the left-hand side don't feel like
they have a lot of control over their
lives
and you can see that each of those
slopes are positive for the young middle
and older person but it's the younger
people the red line that's out of all of
them so younger people are the most
reactive increases in interpersonal
stressors compared to those in midlife
and in older ages and if we look at the
right side of the finger people who feel
that they do not have a lot of obstacles
in their way they feel like they
actually have a decent amount of control
those lines are not they do have a
positive slope but they're not as steep
as on the left so now having high
amounts of control is equally beneficial
for all
each groups on the right-hand side so
what we see is why is it that younger
adults are having such a problem there's
a social emotional selectivity theory
that suggests that emotion regulation
increases with age so we become experts
in our own environments and middle age
and older people have more experience
responding to stressors so perhaps we're
seeing some strengths associated with
aging but younger people are still
trying to figure out how they can
regulate their emotions in in these
somewhat novel experiences in terms of
their life stage we've also applied this
reactivity effect in looking at aging
attitudes so the previous study was
about how old people actually were and
in this study where we had only older
people aged sixty to ninety six we asked
them to report how they felt about their
aging so people who felt really positive
about their aging might say something
like I'm just as happy now as I was when
I was younger but someone who may feel
negative about their aging may say
something like keep getting worse as I
get older so the attitudes towards own
aging that ATO a acronym is represented
in these two lines on this figure and
people who felt pretty negative about
their aging were much more reactive to
daily stresses when they increase so
this positive line is quite speak for
people who felt that their aging was not
going well
so these aging attitudes if they were
negative were almost the vulnerability
factor are like a stress diathesis say
they increased negative affect and
response to stressors we've also looked
at these aging attitudes generally and
how they may interact with daily
experiences about aging so in this paper
which again focused on a sample of
exclusively older adults we asked people
to report each day on their awareness of
age-related change experiences so this a
RC acronym that appears on the
horizontal axis of the figure here for
first awareness of age-related changes
periences so these are things that
highlight aging they aren't necessarily
stressors but maybe they might form
so we asked people to report on how
frequently each day they might have an
awareness of age-related changes where
something might be like I felt today
that my memory was slower than usual
because of my aging so that would be a
loss based of that where they felt like
their aging was highlighted and it was
not a positive association so for people
who felt in general looking at this
black line for people who felt in
general that their aging was going
really well when they had increases in
these daily arc experiences so they felt
like their memory was slower on a given
day and other kinds of daily experiences
that might highlight their aging they
were the ones who are the most reactive
to those experiences they have the worst
negative mood or their their negative
mood increase the most so it's somewhat
interesting that we might think oh it's
always good to feel great about your
aging but this would suggest that that's
not always true if you're really good
about our your aging but then you're
confronted with the daily experience
that might confront your or challenge
your date you're every more general
perception those people would be the
most vulnerable those kinds of
experiences we've also applied this
reactivity paradigm to substance use and
substance craving and so in a sample of
offenders exclusively men we had people
call into an interactive voice response
survey line so when they were released
from jail we recruited them into the
study and they were given a 1-800 number
that they could call each day for 14
days and there of course the missing
data but the nice thing about this
paradigm or this method is that people
who are released from jail don't always
have a stable place to go so regardless
of where they might be staying as long
as they could find a phone payphone or
someone else's phone they could freely
participate in this study so what we
were able to show is here we're
predicting illegal drug cravings so men
they were all men in this case
men who did not have a lot of prior
treatment for their substance abuse that
they would be reflect on the red line
they were the most reactive to increases
in daily stressors their daily illegal
drug craving increased substantially
more compared to the men who had been in
prior treatment many times now we also
use these same predictors for the actual
use of illegal drugs and again prior
treatment seems to be beneficial where
the red line suggests that men who had
not had a lot of prior treatment were
more likely to use drugs with increases
in stressors after eldest slide the
bright side of prior treatment because
there also appears to be enough I'd of
fair treatment here I'm predicting the
frequency of stressors the next day and
in this instance is the black line that
is the positive slope so the men who had
been in prior treatment many times and
for some of these men that was 30 times
so they've been in treatment many times
they had a steeper slope that linked
their drug use yesterday with their
stress rate exposure the next day and we
think it's possible that men who have
needed to be in treatment up to thirty
times they have an especially pernicious
front you see problem or an addiction
and so it might reflect the severity of
their addiction but they also may have
been treatment many times and are aware
that drug use yesterday puts them at
higher risk for exposure to stressors
next day so what I'd like to do in the
future is to work with the colleague on
my department Sarah Desmarais who is a
co-author on that paper and we have
access to all of the wait county jail
booking 67,000 slightly more than that
over a period of several years and we
would like to look at the scale of the
opioid crisis within our particular
County to see if we can descriptively
understand how the national epidemic
might be playing out locally and also to
see if it's getting worse over time
because we do have multiple years of
data so if we could ask about sexual and
individual differences that might modify
increases in opioid use something I of
course would be interested in if you
whether they're on each
and the trends of increases over time so
is it possible that older adults might
be more vulnerable in opioid use because
of age-related pain they might be
experiencing something that we might see
as as we look at these data so that's
something I'd like to do in the near
future the next area but I would like to
subscribe in terms of my work would be
the antecedent what comes before the
stressed cells and so I recently put
together a special section for the
journal gerontology is like sciences and
together with some co-authors we decided
to generate a fuel model that tries to
explain or at least articulate the ways
in which we think age differences might
be playing out in the processes before
stress is before we anticipate or before
we are exposed to stress so this is the
conceptual model that we articulated and
this red box that I've highlighted this
area to the right essentially summarizes
all of the work that goes into my
reactivity piece of the research that
I'm doing so the stress occurs on the
bottom and then there's a stress
response which may be modified by coping
in some way and it's not the two
important outcomes you make care about
so this red box has been thoroughly
studied in my lab and in many other labs
it's really important works about what
happens after but what we wanted to do
in this particular special section was
to talk about all the processes that
might occur before stress so proactive
coping would be efforts that someone
would use to try to prevent a stressor
or to modify it before it happened so
it's not quite as bad when it does
happen there's also anticipatory stress
which we broke into two different kinds
of constructs for us or forecasting is
the prediction that a stressful event
will happen so you think anything
stressful will happen today so it's a
specified or defined time frame so it's
predicting an event where a stress
anticipation is the prediction of a
field so it's the expectation of stress
level and find time frame so how
stressful do you expect to be
we'll be so the dress forecasting is
prediction of an event where a
specification is prediction of a feeling
and we think both of these may be really
important for anticipatory stress that
they may be directly related to these
important outcomes that have been a
feature of many of the stress research
up until now
anticipatory coping would be coping that
is in preparation for a stressor that is
likely to happen it can no longer be
avoided it is likely to be coming in the
future so what can people do prepare for
the consequences of that stressor that
can no longer be avoided so we took
these pieces and in my lab we've been
very interested in forecaster things
because we have these different domains
of stressors we ask people to make a
prediction for the next day the forecast
their stress so how likely is it that
you would have argument an avoidable
argument for a home stressor social
network stressor and then we see that
there are a lot of individual
differences that's the blue part of
these pie charts but there's also a lot
of fluctuation across the day so there's
within person variability that's
represented by these red pieces of pie
so we have evidence to suggest that
forecasts are made in a contextually
specific and changing way with a person
over time so we found that that was
interesting and then we wanted to look
to see if those forecasts were important
for how people responded to the
stressors that they forecasted about so
in this particular figure we're looking
at the domain of foam stressors and in
our sample this usually was people
feeling they had too much to do at home
or need to do some sort of household
maintenance and we have younger adults
represented on the left hand side of the
figure and older adults represented on
the right hand side and the solid black
line in both cases reflects this
anticipatory response this idea that if
you forecast a stressor so forecast is
increasing but the stressor itself does
not happen there's still an emotional
cost to that
so the
anticipatory process still has this
emotional consequence and that's true
regardless of age but what we found
really interesting was that in the
domain of home stressors when younger
adults were able to forecast so they are
able to see in the future or predict in
the future that something stressful at
home will happen this was very
beneficial for their mood it reduced
their negative affect whereas for older
adults there wasn't quite such a strong
benefit as for the younger adults and we
feel like this could be related to Susan
Charles strength and a vulnerability
integration theory where she suggests
that older adults have or their there
are strengths and vulnerabilities that
accompany aging so the strengths of
older people in this case might be in
avoiding the stressor in the first place
but once the stressor is no longer able
to be avoided then there's the full nura
bility and how they may be able to
respond so in this case that the
forecasting is really beneficial for
younger adults relative older adults
we've also applied this to the 2016
presidential election we didn't
necessarily set out to examine the
impact of the election but we just
happen to be collecting data in October
and November of 2016 so in October we
have 78 participants reporting on 645 to
total days and then in the week
surrounding the election which took
place on November 8th 716 29
participants reporting on 235 days so we
compared the election sample and the
comparison sample on their forecasted
next day stressors their actual
stressors and their negative effect and
what we see here on the vertical axis is
been predicting negative effect or
feelings of bad mood in the comparison
sample the timing of the study whether
it was the beginning or the end of their
study week didn't matter of the black
line and the dashed grey lines are
nearly identical in terms of their
overlap but if we look at the election
subsample on the right hand side so
black line
like the days after the election and the
rayline reflects the days before the
election so this is within the same
people we see that there's an expected
reaction increases occurs negative food
also goes up but this becomes even more
pronounced and stronger and the day is
past the election so it's important to
note that these are the same people
right these with in-person slopes the
SUBSCRIBE reactivity changed and they
increase in the days after the election
so what I'd like to do in the future is
to dive into some data that we collected
this year where we have information from
a Czech presidential candidate this flag
is from the Czech Republic so I was able
to collect data from the presidential
candidate himself in the campaign phase
the election things and the recovery
phase after the election and so this
these lines reflect various health and
well-being indicators and you can see
the data started to be collected in
December of 2017 the election was a
Tuesday election it took place January
12 to 13 of 2018 and so we can look at
trends and patterns of health and
well-being in the campaign phase the
election days and the recovery phase and
we have this information for the
presidential candidate for his romantic
partner so we can see again the election
phase reflected here and the health and
well-being indicators as they travel
together over time and then we also have
the same information from the romantic
there from the adult sign of the
candidate so we're excited to get into
these data and try to understand very
stressful but also intensely personal
and relevant series of stressors that
are related to to going through the
presidential election as the candidate
himself so we've looked at the u.s.
presidential election we're going to
look at the Czech presidential election
though this year what we wanted to do in
my lab was to look at the 2018 midterm
election and do it intentionally so I
was a
to receive a grant to look at the
campaign phase that we we began October
15th leading up to the midterm election
which was on November 6th and then to
look at the recovery phase in the one
week after the midterm election and many
of the elections results were not known
on November 6th they spilled over into
the several days remaining silver but
it's a sample of about 140 people from
across the u.s. reporting on their daily
experiences with the election itself and
to see how they respond as they if they
move through his face so the last thing
I want to talk about is the the
timescales in which these processes have
been the short and long term
inter-individual variability so this
quote is from John Nesselrode the idea
that the coexistence of two kinds of
inter individual changes are key to a
really understanding everyday lives so
I've spent this talk talking a lot about
intra-individual variability this up and
down kind of rollercoaster variability I
think the fact to move up and down
stress move up and down now the things
that I'm looking at a daily basis really
do fluctuate and go up and down but it
happens within the context of longer
term in for individual change that
unfold over decades and much longer
timescales so trying to integrate these
two would be really important to
understanding everyday lives so I have
an ro1 with Tom Hess that's a social
cognition and aging grant from the
National Institute on Aging where we're
trying to systematically
look at inter-individual variability and
change over long timescales so we have
effort here at cognitive cost predicting
intrinsic motivation and we
operationalize effort systolic blood
pressure response so we have people come
in to the lab and we give them a series
of cognitive tests and we look at their
their blood pressure their heart rate
and many psychophysiological indicators
as they are doing those testings and
then we index that as efforts and we
look to see if there if that relates to
their motivation to
to be involved in activities we see is
true that this effort very much is
related to their their ability their
willingness to engage in activities and
so we also wanted to look to see if
teaching attitudes how people felt in
general about their aging would mediate
this relationship and we see that it
does so when people have more effort in
terms of doing cognitive thing that
relates to how they feel about their
aging which in turn relates to their
motivation to be involved in various
activities what we like in the future
for this project to continue looking at
these two different kinds of
intra-individual variability and change
is to capture the ways in which the
weekly assessments that we have
absolutely believed the lab we asked
about their activity engagement how that
may unfold and so we asked them if they
have participated in social activities
or in cognitive activities in physical
activities and so we have them answer
these questions once a week for five
weeks after they leave the lab so we
have this long-term change but we've
people have been in the study for thirty
years so we have these longer-term
investments and now we're able to match
that with the shorter term assessments
we also recently received Alzheimer's
and Alzheimer supplement for this
project with the goal to identify
behavioral and physiological drivers
that may slow or accelerate the
trajectory of activities so again trying
to predict activities engagement and so
the first aim is to extend tom has his
theory of selective engagement so his
set idea of selective engagement theory
and its implications Alzheimer's disease
and related dementia so select engage
this idea that as it becomes more
effortful to participate or to engage in
cognitive paths that people will
dedicate their recent makes the most for
them in terms of their goals and so
we're going to integrate chronic stress
to build a comprehensive model of reason
cognizant
Kermit and the way we're gonna do that
is to look at a hundred people with
cognitive impairment or related dementia
and we're going to have them view the
same aspect as the the parent project
and we are going to have them take the
harmonized
cognitive assessment protocol which is
used in the health and retirement study
it's an expand assessment of cognitive
function that we can administer to the
participants if they are able or to a
proxy respondent if they have someone
who comes with them you can tell us
about their emotions and we're going to
get up there chronic stress by taking
their hair so we're going to be using
three centimeters of their hair shorter
obviously if they don't have that long
of hair to represent their total
cortisol output in the past eight months
so however long hair we can get we'll
index their chronic stress and how their
prospective experience to may relate to
their cognitive functioning so we will
of course go very out the important
things that will help us understand the
chronic stress from the hair and at that
point we're excited to go forward so
this is this is a where I will I will
turn it back over to you thank you thank
you so much it's a pretty nice
presentation so I have one or two
questions vegetarians regarding like
have you looked at the like these are
the individual people right like
whatever you have studies have done with
individuals have you looked at their
families like as a family has a
particular type of stress stress
response yeah that's a great question
there's one study that I've done with
Keith Whitfield it came out in I believe
it came out in 2012 or 2014 the journal
i think is ethnicity and disease where
we look at the intergenerational
transmission of stress and how that can
influence cardiovascular health in
african-american families so that those
data are from the Jackson Heart Study
and so that's an interesting paper where
we show that
adults who have parents who experience
stress and who did not live very long so
had short lives you know have have a
response one way to their own stressors
so yeah that that is is fascinating to
me to think about generations and how
stress and response to stress can be
transmitted through families I also have
done some work with Jeremy or gassen who
is it BYU he's very interested in
marital relationship so couples within a
couple how do marital partners influence
each other and how they respond to their
own stress so I've done some work like
that but I certainly credited I call it
being the driving force behind those
kinds of questions and one more thing
regarding seem like a marital thing like
there are like lots of in you yes you
have a single family parents so how the
kiss have like they have gone through
the stresses in their lives how does it
affect their long-term well-being
anything has been done on that like you
have a single family kids right were
raised in single family so they might
have some stressors or period because
having one person taking care of them so
their long-term effect is then as
anybody done on that any work on that
yes I that if that's not work that has
been done directly in my lab I am aware
of several bodies of work that might
help with that kind of question so
there's some work on divorce in general
so parent families that may have started
as two-parent households but then
transition to be headed by a single
parent there's some work on how house
children can have resilient outcomes so
certainly it's not always the case that
having a single parent predicts
necessarily how the child will deal with
their own stress as a child but then
also as an older adults I could do one
paper with Dave Almeida and Melanie
Horne
she's now Melanie Horne Mellors where we
asked people to retrospective your
report
the quality of their relationships with
their parents when they were younger so
we asked them to report on the warmth
and the understanding that they felt
that they had from their parents and
adults who retrospective the
relationships with their parents were
better at handling stressors as an adult
compared to people who felt that they
had less warm or cold relationship with
their parents so I think that the
quality of the relationship definitely
is an important thing to consider and
the structure of the family certainly
may play a role it may create some
challenges but certainly those
challenges can be overcome so I think
that the quality is the important piece
to remember so anything on the genetics
people I worked on looked into and how
people cope with the stressors yeah so
Keith Whitfield who's now the provost at
Wayne State University does a lot of
behavior genetics work and he does it
within the context of the
intergenerational transmission of stress
and how people respond to stress so his
work I think is is speaking to that kind
of question that you raised but yeah
it's a there's a lot of work may be done
we still don't understand all the
mechanisms whether they're genetic or
environmental or certainly a combination
and coming to the last your discussion
on alzhiemer's like is there like
because usually sometimes part of aza
mercy is kind of a genetic there is a I
mean like some data on that so how how
do you look at is there any like piece
you are adding there or no it's just
like totally different than what you are
looking into we are we won't be able to
look at the determinants necessarily of
Alzheimer's disease its onset have
potentially half of the sample that we
will collect has been in the has been in
a research study for decades and so we
would know about their behaviors many
years ago and how that might relate to
their subsequent diagnosis of impairment
but we will also be collecting data from
new participants in the community so we
won't have that historical kind of an
Meishan but this grant is specifically
looking at behavioral aspects and
physiological predictor of cortisol from
one chronic stress so we won't really be
looking at genetic factors but that
would be something that would be a nice
fraction for future work and one more
this is the last one regarding the again
alzhiemer's like parents are like you
have your parents well as dimers so is
there any study done on like a looking
at their kids or grandkids hey how do
they like they might like since there is
a genetic component to house immerse how
their that stress level eventually end
up ten years five years down the road
like any work has been done on that I'm
not aware of any that doesn't exist I'm
not aware of any but I think it's
fascinating right because now people
have the relatively inexpensive
possibility to have their genetic
screening done by these companies that
where you know you send in your cotton
swab with your saliva and they can tell
you your health risk for something like
Alzheimer's disease late and early onset
and so I think it's it's a practical
question what might be a predictor of
someone being interested in knowing that
information or wanting to avoid knowing
that information are there some some
fears or some anxieties that are very
real in how people might approach that
kind of information about their own
personal self and what might be their
personal health future but then also may
that be make could that be a stressor
that family is anticipating years in
advance yes that would be very
interesting to know how people's
thoughts about that potential upcoming
diagnosis may influence their behavior
right now yeah so that would be
interesting study too I agree yeah thank
you so much I really appreciate your
time so it will be on our website in
next cup already it will be there as
soon as we are done but it will be on
the front page in the next few days
great thank you so much thank you bye